hey guys just wanted to give you a quick
update about the plans for the channel
as you're probably going to
see
things that are confusing i don't know
i don't know what people are going to
think about it but i just want to make
my plan for this year
clear i'm still working it out in my
head my goal ultimately is to get to
working on
the main game i want to work on there's
a couple little side ones but i really
want to work on this game
and
the reality is it takes a lot of time
and energy to get much done so
i'm looking for support of course i
don't really know how to ask for support
so what i'm kind of doing instead is i'm
going to try to get as many
good tutorials out
as possible at the beginning of the year
that way
hopefully
they kind of carry my channel so that i
can take some down time to actually work
on
the stuff i want to work on and uh i do
want to do devlogs on them but i don't
know it's i'm keep i want to keep the
project pretty private until it's
actually ready for a demo
so
the dev logs on this one are going to be
tricky but i think i can manage to keep
doing these game engine coding quickie
videos that i've been doing people seem
to like those
uh just about things i learned but more
kind of unrelated to the context of my
project now
i've made videos on
the synopsis of the project so it's
nothing new it's it's extended stay i
made a video talking about it but
basically
uh i'm not going to get into it again
it's it's still a little
unclear in my head but uh
it's going to be a lot of work
and i realized that and i also realized
that in general it's going to be a lot
of unpaid work and i'm okay with that
you guys probably kind of realized it
that's kind of how it is on youtube for
a long time anyway you do a ton of
unpaid work
but i am sort to the point where i can
like release videos and expect them to
do it at least a tiny bit of something
so that's nice and of course the members
of my channel on patreon and here on
youtube do help a ton
so that's kind of the main
way of support right now
so yeah that's where it's at
um
i guess if you really want to see
where the stuff is at you can join any
of the source tiers which is a little
more expensive but also i will be quick
to answer your questions especially
about coding and stuff
uh on that tier but that's where the
latest game engine versions are
and that's the one i'll be working on
throughout the year
the game files are going to be separate
of course because the game engine is
just the library to load in all the
media and logic and stuff for the game
so i should still be able to manage to
keep that private even while
having the main engine available to at
least some people who uh want the extra
stuff so that's that's the plan for this
year basically try to bust out as many
uh
tutorials easy
easy for me videos which actually aren't
as easy as they seem like the blender
ones took me so many hours to get those
edited
somewhat due to my
well i don't know i was debating it's
like do i just re-record this or do i
just edit my mistakes
i don't know what the right answer is
there i don't want to keep recording the
same video
so you just kind of have to go with it
after a while and release what you got
and that's
that's what i'm doing i hope they do
well i hope they help people
there's definitely some new changes in
blender 3.0 with the video editing stuff
and my previous videos
on such a topic did decently in the
years before so i'm hoping that they
help people and help carry the channel
some
in this new year
so that i can get a little freedom
to work on my own thing and uh
do my own goals because
well as much as i
enjoy helping people making tutorials
it's it's not exactly my dream it's just
kind of something
i do on the side i don't know if that
makes total sense to everybody but
i think most
teachers their dream isn't exactly to be
a teacher it's they're just usually
doing that to kind of support their
other interests and you might as well
teach something if you're getting good
at it
because why not you know you might as
well even if you're just getting an
apprentice or something it's kind of a
waste to learn a bunch of stuff and
never pass along the knowledge so
i really do appreciate you guys uh
i guess soaking it in and leaving
comments and stuff all right well that's
that's my plan as of right now for the
new year i hope you'll stick around and
support me and uh all that good stuff so
love you guys have a good year peace out